on va jouer à twitter qui leur tend je
connais si ces sites twitter killers et
rsa est ce que vous pouvez mettre ça
là-bas bachiri merci twitter qui leur a
bah on va devoir dessoûler de celui qui
fait le plus petit chiffre qui devra
twitté instantanément quelque chose par
exemple le premier tweet
on va devoir faire ses salut tout le
monde j'ai une gastro de ouf mon slip
jaune est devenu léopard c'est habituel
mais surtout souligner alors magique
celui donc qui fait le plus petit
chiffre il envoie tout ça et tout ça
toutefois l'autre des ces bizarres qui
prennent le blanc c'est vrai c'est vrai
ce que tu veux vraiment je vais tenir à
l'étude et marty vais aller bien combien
vous allez leur site énorme ouais
égalité
donc on va dire que je suis la personne
le tweet d'accord c'est bien on passe au
deuxième but attention je kiffe le boule
de dj snake fille de 7 ans vois ça je
sais que c'est ton pote je lève aussi
beaucoup elle était partie attention on
y va
ça me dérange pas ça devienne pas le
faire je vais lutter dans un instant
vous le dis je kiffe le bull depuis des
semaines et le dernier il est beaucoup
plus compliqué ouais j'ai vu prendre
gastambide tout nu il a un petit zizi ah
ouais ça s'est fait très chaud parce
qu'il sait que c'est vrai lui donc ça
c'est pas envie de tweetie tu vois mais
ouais parce que ça va sauter la passe
quoi tu connais si je tweet c'est mentir
aux us et sur ie9 azim avait ni eau
ah bin là donc je vais tout et coup sur
coup jeudi ce n'est qu'un pool room
gastambide
je le fais l'ancienne coutume mais dans
un même tweet alors est-ce que tu meures
non je pense que je vais mettre d'abord
dj snake monde en une heure est ce que
tu préfères
je préfère que batman dark hummer un
seul tweet
ouais j'aime beaucoup le boule de dj
snake est également je trouve que franck
gastambide un petit 6 voilà un seul
tweet est bien juste le cas poursuit je
vais voir